How can I find out if my cancer is getting better or not? I'm feeling really well, but just want to know.
Well, again, the best way to know if your cancer is improving or not is to prepare apples to
apples with a test, but just like that last question, if you had a CT scan to diagnose the cancer
in the first place, it's quite often you're not going to be eligible to get another CT scan because
you made up doing the therapy that the oncologist is asking you to do, or you may not want to do another
CT scan because of the radiation involved. So you can't compare apples to apples. So let's say
you could compare apples to apples, that would be the best way to know objectively whether your
problem is improving or not. But there are other ways. So let's say I can't compare apples to
apples for whatever reason. Had a CT scan, don't want to do it again or not eligible to do it again.
Change my insurance, whatever. Are there other ways? Yes, there's blood work to objectively look at
things. Remember, everything's just going to give you clues. So let's say I do blood work and I have
do a tumor marker test and I show positive CA 125 of my tumor marker tested and subsequent to
a worker test and stay the same or it's going down. Those are good signs. If it doubled or tripled,
that's not a good sign. Even if you're feeling better, you've got to look at subjective and
objective data. So I'm feeling really good. But my CA 125 went from 42 to 260. The
last time I did it was 42, now it's 260. That's not good. So that's not good. So we do want to dig
a little deeper. We may want to do some other objective tests. We may want to find out what's going
up. But that's saying my CA 125 was 42 and now it's 42. Again, I know it's 38 or now it's 46.
You know, it's right around that same number. There's a margin of error in all these testing.
And I'd say, hey, and you're feeling well, you're comparing that to subjective findings. And let's say
that was the only thing abnormal of your blood work. And I'd say you're probably doing really well.
So it's, we just keep monitoring. So we use whatever objective data we can to to find out with,
you know, to whatever degree you're comfortable in going. I don't want to do another MRI. I don't
want to do another PET scan. Okay. Well, let's do blood work. Could you would you do that? Yes,
I'll do that. And we'll use that as our objective data to give us the clues that we need to know
whether you're getting worse or getting better. And you compare that to with your subjective data,
I'm feeling real well. You know, I, there's lots of clues just in a CDC with differential and a
comprehensive metabolic profile at a tumor marker panel that could give us objective data that could,
you know, tell us which way we're going. So relatively inexpensive for a few hundred dollars,
we could kind of get a good picture of what's going on and how we're doing. Like I said,
if just to the CDC with differential, if I had a normal CBC, you know, three months ago,
and I want to know how I cancers do it, but I don't want to do anything other than a blood work. And
now my CBC shows, you know, an anemia, as well as, you know, other things on a cup,
heads of metabolic profile or a tumor marker panel, that would tell us that we're not going to
the right direction. And we either, we need to tweak your protocol. We need to change things. We
need to do a other cheek swab test. We need to consider speaking to an ecologist. We need to do
something different if our objective data and or subjective data is going the wrong direction.